20th anniversary of smallville you and i
just did a bunch of press we promoted
the blu-ray that's coming out yeah this
will probably be already out by the time
this airs yeah but um
and you always get offended upset when
people say 20th anniversary and you're
like it's not from the time it ended
it's from the time it started
20 years
20 years since you started smallville
and i've talked to you about this how
much do you think
if you when you look back at starting
the show
i mean it's got to be a daunting thing
or were you just so naive and just young
and giddy and all that that you just
didn't realize what a daunting task it
was to play the lead role in a huge
series well the funny thing is i was
sold on the idea that it was ensemble
ensemble means there was the rest of the
cast to do some of the work so that was
the naivete that you're talking about to
me
it was a it was a job cool i've never
been to vancouver let's go and then i
got in front of all you guys and you
guys knew what like
marks were and
where like how where the light should be
and stuff and i was like oh boy i better
i better learn fast so yeah i had no
idea i just knew it was a great job
and i hope it would work and that's how
it
continued and we ended up lasting 10
years i mean that was a yeah i think
there's less than 30 tv shows in the
history of television is that true
wow there's not a lot were you nervous
though honestly were you acting for the
like really for the first time you've
done some small things but like doing
scenes in the very beginning do you
remember how you felt do you remember
overwhelmed do you remember like can i
do this can i can i get through it were
you embarrassed at all the crew's
watching the cast everybody were you
because you're so young and you just had
to do some done some modeling and like
you did the amy show
judging amy but you hadn't done a lot
well i would have been a nervous
wreck she was a that that judging amy
experience was awesome for me because i
got to act with her
and i saw the way she operated on set
and how she treated people and how when
the camera started and i don't know if i
knew this at the time but then she would
like
then we would just be in the scene it
would just be talking to each other a
lot like you and i did right and
in some ways when smuggled happened
again i thought it was
i thought it was an ensemble
but many times especially in the first
season i'm like where's everybody else
yeah michael was just here and he left
kristen's now here she left right they
must be doing other things right no they
went home um but
the camera
i don't mean to sound like whatever but
the camera never never bothers me never
has never has like i don't see it
and and thank god that's rare light's
rare i'm just
think even in the beginning even when
you're first doing these few scenes you
weren't thinking oh my god am i selling
it am i doing the right thing am i no if
anything else i never felt like i
i i looked to
like the directors and producers or the
other actors
and be like did i not that i get away
with that but like when they move on i'm
like okay i don't know if it's good or
not
but i wasn't like
oh no
because i just thought that other people
should tell me if i was doing bad yeah i
don't know and we that our relationship
was a little bit like that where you'd
we'd be in a scene he'd be like just do
that again do that again like you can do
better or whatever like that that was
helpful and i was like okay it's cool
but i kind of looked for other people to
guide me innately so
you know if somebody was like that was
shitty i was like okay well how do we
adjust it right and i don't know where i
got that from or what not you i don't
know if
i don't want to be arrogant and say i
don't know if you can teach that i was
just so focused on the job
that i don't know if so you've never
really cared about what other people
think is what you're saying well i cared
about the people around me who thought
but like as we've talked about social
media wasn't a thing or commenting about
episodes wasn't really right but you
know if there were times where you you
know we would
i just relied on other people i think
that's the answer i relied on other
people to help to support me and if they
said we needed more i'll do more they
said we got it we got it
you